you know how all the Marvel movies are
part of the Marvel Universe I think
every Vince Vaughn movie is part of the
Vince Vaughn averse in which Vince
Vaughn plays the same character but he
gets a new alias and a new identity
because of that guy from Breaking Bad
because Vince Vaughn undeniably plays
the same character in everything the
Vince Vaughn averse it's real
[Music]
delivery man delivery mantle story
starring Vince Vaughn this guy donated a
lot of sperm back in the 90s and now it
turns out he has about 533 kids roaming
around out there and all of them want to
know who is my father and because of a
legal dispute they might be entitled to
find out who might not be hey that's the
point of the movie a movie that's
enjoyable and has a bit of heart to it
yeah like I said Vince Vaughn is the
same character in this movie as he was
in dodgeball as he was in the internship
it's Vince Vaughn it's been fun playing
Vince Vaughn but it turns out in this
movie he donated a lot of sperm and he
got a lot of money for it in the 90s
which I thought was we live in
a world where you can get paid for
rubbing one out that is I've
been doing that for free for years but
this Vaughn can't just come out and
expose himself I go hey I'm me because
you never know maybe these kids want
money my kids I mean 17 and 19 years old
that's how old these kids are so what he
does he has a packet of the kids who
want to find out who he is and he
ultimately he tells him he follows him
around he finds out about their lives
and he plays some guardian angel type
role you know he helps him out where he
can like if one of his kids gets a flat
tire he'll be the guy who rolls up right
by him like hey I got a spare tire here
just helping you out and so he starts
bonding with these people which is
optimal any father out there will be
like if I could do it that's how I'd do
it a couple of times in the movie the
movie gets real like dramatic not a
shitty Wayne actually a really good way
you step back for a second you're like
whoa I didn't expect that from a movie
from the Vince Vaughn averse goodjob
movie well played there are a couple of
plot lines in the movie I was like why
is that in there like one of his kids
he's kind of a bad egg he's a weirdo you
can all be he's a psycho he's a psycho
feel bad from all you want but in the
end you really want to go and hang out
with this guy you don't he's like
hanging out with me or I'm going to
expose you and so he just starts
creeping on Vince Vaughn and he's like
no we're gonna hang out we're gonna go
to the park here take me to your
basketball game so immediately he's this
douchebag bad egg who's intruding on
Vince Vaughn's life and he's intruding
on the entire movie you're watching him
you're like please go away so I can get
back to enjoying this we had a nice
heartfelt character growth bonding type
movie we didn't need the weirdo weighing
the whole thing down funny thing though
you get your wish he goes away you never
see it for the rest of the movie what
happened to him I don't know you never
know the movie doesn't tell you and at
that point you feel like the movie
wasted your time another thing is Vince
Vaughn owes a lot of money to a lot of
people you want to establish this
because he needs to have financial
problems he needs to be in a bad spot I
get it plot lines then the mob starts
come
- like we want our money and then that
stops happening and you're like okay
well let's that was in the movie I guess
because really if you want to put Vince
Vaughn in a bad financial spot where he
needs a lot of money make his father's
business go under this movie is actually
a remake it's based on another movie I
haven't seen the movie but maybe these
mobsters and the weirdo they were in the
movie and so they have to put them in
this movie otherwise it's not a remake
it's not true to form I'm just saying
these weird off the cuff side stories
that happen a couple times you never see
him again they just they just feel out
of place in the end delivery man was
funny it was enjoyable it had a
surprising amount of heart Vince Vaughn
does play the same character he plays in
everything I actually enjoyed this one
more than I thought I was going to enjoy
it I was like okay I've seen all the
Vince Vaughn movies at this point show
me something new I'm not saying the
entire thing was new I'm saying the
whole thing was enjoyable so I'm gonna
say delivery man is a good time no
alcohol required the Vince Vaughn never
strikes again alright so your favorite
and least favorite Vince Vaughn movies I
think he has made enough - we can assess
something like this whatever they are
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]